what do you think happens after we die
i think
mind and life
go away completely
when we die
and
i think
that's actually significantly important
for the kind of beings that we are
um
we are the kinds of beings that can come
to that awareness and then we have a
responsibility
to decide how we're going to comport
ourselves towards it
can you linger on what that means the
mind goes away
like when
you're playing music
and the last instrument is put down the
song is over
doesn't mean the song wasn't beautiful
doesn't mean the song wasn't complex
doesn't mean the song
like didn't add to the value of the
universe in its existence but it came to
an end
is there some aspect
in which some part of mind was there
before the human
and remains after
something like pan psychism or is it too
much for us limited cognitive beings to
understand
something like pan psychism um i take it
seriously i don't think it's a
ridiculous proposal but i think it has
insoluble problems
that make me doubt it
any idea that the mind is some kind of
ultimately immaterial substance also has
for me just
devastating problems those are the two
kinds of framework that people usually
propose
in order to support some kind of idea of
immortality i find both very problematic
the fact that we participate
in distributed cognition that most of
our problem solving is not done as
individuals but in groups this is
something i work on i've published on
that i think that's important
but
uh most of the people who do work on
systems of distributed cognition think
that while there's such a thing as
collective intelligence
there's no good evidence that there's
collective consciousness in fact it's
often called zombie agency for that
reason
and so
while i think it's very clear that no
one person runs an airline
and there's a collective intelligence
that solves that problem i do not think
that collective intelligence supports
any kind of consciousness
and so therefore i don't think the fact
that i participate which i regularly and
reliably do in distributed cognition
gives me any reason to believe that that
participation
grounds some kind of consciousness
okay there's so many things to mention
there first of all distributed cognition
maybe that's a synonym for collective
intelligence so that means a bunch of
humans
individually are able to think
have cognitive machines
and uh are somehow able to interact
through the process of dialogue as you
talk about
to um
morph different ideas together like this
ideal landscape together
it's so interesting to think about okay
well you do have
these fascinating
distributed cognition systems
but consciousness
does not
propagate in the same way as
intelligence yeah but
isn't there a case if we just look at
intelligence if we look at us humans as
a collection of smaller organisms yes
which we are and
and so there's like a hierarchy
of organisms tiny ones
work together to form
tiny villages that you can then start to
see as individual organisms that are
then also forming
bigger villages and interact in
different ways and function becomes more
and more complex and eventually we get
to us humans
to where we start to think well we're an
individual but really we're not there's
billions of organisms inside us sure are
both domestic and foreign
so uh
isn't that
building up consciousnesses
like turtles all the way up to us our
consciousness why does it have to stop
with us humans are we the only like is
this the face transition when it becomes
a
zombie-like
giant hierarchical village that first
like ah there's like a singing angels
and it's consciousness is born in just
us humans
do bacteria have consciousness uh not
bacteria but maybe you could say
bacteria does but like the interesting
complicated organisms that are within us
have consciousness i think it's proper
to argue and i have that like a
paramecium or bacteria
has a kind of agency and even a kind of
intelligence uh kind of sense-making
ability but
i do not think that we can attribute
consciousness at least what we mean by
consciousness this kind of
self-awareness this ability to
introspect
etc etc
to bacteria now the reason why
distributed cognition doesn't have
consciousness i think it's a little bit
more tricky
and i think there's no reason in
principle
why
there couldn't be a consciousness for
distributed cognition
collective intelligence
in fact many you know philosophers would
agree with me on that point i think it's
more an issue of certain
empirical facts
bandwidth
density of connection speed of
information transfer etc
it's conceivable that if we got some
horrible frankensteinian neural link and
we linked our brains and we had the
right density and dynamics and bandwidth
and speed
that a group consciousness could take
shape i don't have any argument in
principle against that i'm just saying
those those contingent facts do not yet
exist and therefore it is implausible
that consciousness exists at the level
of collective intelligence
you